foreign
this is [__] great man yeah you like
it yeah yeah I mean you've been uh all
the podcast so that's a big compliment
yeah this is really [__] nice I
always aspired uh to be Rogan of the UK
we all did so I was like let me get a
big [__] table no Rogan's so Rogan's
table his initial table
was pretty close Tommy and I were
talking about and he was like I think
you should get out of the uh the couch
game and get a table only got a table
and I found that my interviews I found
I'm not as relaxed oh really you feel
it's a bit more formal for me but I
enjoy being interviewed on the table
more personally
uh but I found that I uh I don't let
them talk very much and I'm on top of
them and I'm not very relaxed and I'm
nervous that they're not doing well
really that's right I just I I and this
is why I'm such a fan of the space I
just uh we just bought a house and built
out a whole podcast Studio to make it a
little more homey a little more relaxed
a little more casual because that was my
first podcast Studio man I get so [__]
up a podcast because my first investment
was like roughly 800 really 800 I
remember getting paid my first ad sales
read and being like
dude this is the best business plan I've
ever 800 I'm getting 1500 an ad read I
did five ad reads the first day my money
on Travel Channel was seven thousand
dollars an episode and I looked at my my
check and I was like five hundreds I was
like I just made the same money roughly
that I made on Travel Channel I'm not
paying agents or managers I didn't leave
my house my investment's 800 I go this
is [__] this I feel like I moved to
San Francisco and I'm selling blue jeans
so Herbert was a Herbert was the first
thing I ever did yeah well I did a show
called The X show and on the X show I
did a segment called hurt Bert yeah
where I took dangerous men's jobs and
then they FX said let's just do that
show and so then we did hurt Bert where
I was an MMA fighter I fought a bear I
was saying I swam of great white sharks
uh it's a bull one as well right I think
I'm all by a bull that was the [__]
worst
that was that was when I realized they
didn't have my Health and Longevity and
interest yeah they didn't give a [__]
about you I I I'm such a [__] I was
like oh yeah the name of the show is
hurt Bert if I don't get hurt we don't
have a show yeah so uh yeah I got mobile
broke my legs broke my broke my leg
broke my foot and broke my ribs I don't
think you'd give yourself enough credit
for podcasting wise because I just
watched your Louis CK one yeah it was
amazing I talked to her from the whole
time no no you guys had like a great
back and forth it was beautiful well
that will
because he he he he plays well with you
and a lot of the comments were like he's
he's a great file for you yeah do you
know what I mean I I work well with uh
guys like Louie and Tom you and Tom are
very very very similar they're very
similar dudes very [__] similar Tom
likes to jerk off in front of it
it's not an elephant in the room when
you're talking to a huge comedian who's
had a scandal are you like no does he
ever bring it up do people bring it up
like or is it just sort of not you don't
even mention it anymore well on a
podcast I'd never bring it up with him
because I don't I'm not that guy like I
don't like confrontation
um I'd make a joke about it definitely
but I didn't even realize I was kind of
digging we were talking about things you
were turned on by and I was showing him
quicksand Porn Bro I was literally just
watching this I was like I've never
heard of this in my life and I've
watched pretty much every porn I can
think of I've watched all of them yeah
I've watched all of them you you were
literally like this is the good bit I
was like wow he's really been watching
oh yeah oh I watched a great deal of
quicksand porn the people that are into
quicksand promo are called sinkers
yeah because I thought right in my uh
you know from the male point of view I'm
like I guess the girls get trapped and
at that point the man comes up and like
he's like oh you need a little out there
but no it's just literally women getting
covered in quickside and then
disappearing yeah
if you'd marry long enough the part when
their mouth goes under is the best part
no it's uh this guy I got I mean there
was I got into a genre of porn called uh
down blousing where it was just all it
is is that because I'm a I'm I get the
re the fakeness of porn takes me out of
it yeah like when you hear a girl like
uh you like that Daddy no one talk I
mean girls ought to have sex with my
wife doesn't talk like that down
blasting was so cool because it's a girl
and like her husband's shirt loose
fitting shirt
uh rubber gloves and she's just cleaning
the toilet talking to you about your day
with no bra and she's like so later
today you want to take the kids up at
soccer or do you want me to and you can
see your tits it's the part that turns
you on in real life
and that's what I connected to that
makes sense yeah because I remember
watching like those um mom porn videos
where they come and they open the door
and they're like in a dressing guy with
a huge tits are like exposed those are
the I mean those are the sexiest moments
in life yeah is when I can still think I
think of things there's times in my life
where I go and not a pervert but like
where a woman has leaned down and
accidentally see her boob and you're
like and you just get a glimpse you
avert your eyes you're not like ah but
you're like whoa that's so much hotter
than any porn anyone's ever gonna make
we're not talking about that as men
because apparently that makes you a
pervert like people forget in order for
us to even still be here as a species we
need to be attracted to women so if a
woman bends over right in front of you
at a gym yeah it doesn't make you a
pervert if you notice it like if you
keep harassing her then you're a pervert
yes but we're allowed to notice things
you're allowed us you're allowed to see
a beautiful woman and go wow she's
gorgeous yeah and then I mean just don't
make a meal out of it yeah you know like
I mean that's I think that that most
regular guys understand that and then
there's guys I've seen them like guys
who are I had a manager one time who
just anytime a girl walked by like look
at that look at that tits on that one
and you're like I'm like what I don't
even want to be my manager do you ever
think about my career like what do you
think about tits I'm trusting you with
my [__] future yeah and all you think
about is tits God damn it so but uh that
I one time I got a lap dance this is my
favorite lap dance I've ever gone okay
so uh we were in Fort Wayne Indiana and
uh we got done a show we go over to this
I wish I remember the name of the strip
club because it's so great managers at
my show he's got girls with he goes why
don't you come over uh just have drinks
whatever you guys want so we go over the
whole crew it's our last show of the
tour and uh I Love Lockdown I love lap
dances I love I love lap dances I love
dances but I love strip clubs mostly
because I grew up in Florida that energy
of a strip club is fun you know it's
like I don't know cigars and guys and
[__] girls are naked and drinks and
everyone's having a good time everyone's
inhibitions are a little let down and so
we go there and I get all the guys lap
dances and I'm I'm not I I usually don't
get lap dances because people can see
you and then if they are watching me get
a lap dance they'll videotape it and I
just that's why I don't know I just kind
of avoid them lately yeah
so this girl's walking out she's fully
dressed it's snowing and she's fully
dressed and she sees me she goes oh my
God
I'm such a fan what what are you doing
here and I said I just had a show I met
and the owner of the managers there I
met him she was ugh if I had known you
were coming over here I wouldn't have
cut early I would have stayed I would
love to have given you a dance and I
said actually the dance I'm looking for
is for someone fully dressed and she's
like huh I said no Let's do let's do a
lap dance but I want to see you go from
she's in a snow coat a hat gloves she's
getting ready to go out in the weather
and I go let's get a lap dance like that
and she goes okay because I've always
had a bit about trying to connect to the
reality of sex and as opposed to go to a
strip club they're half naked she got so
uncomfortable she like had to sit down
to take her boots off and it was the
funniest [__] lap dance of my life in
the irony of you complaining about
people having too many clothes off I
know I've literally seen your [__]
multiple times man yeah I've only just
met you but I watched this uh the coven
uh Series yeah the amount that your ass
is out is crazy
um but also when we're on the topic of
strip clubs yeah they do vary like I've
been to some good ones I've been to some
Horizon ones oh yeah really depressing
you wipe your feet on the way out like
you're like why did I even bother with
this this is I'm actually feeling sorry
for these women here yeah yeah so I've
I've uh I've run the gamut I I lately
have gone way more than ever because
we've been on the road in Europe yeah so
we went in uh is your wife cool with
that yeah you shouldn't give a [__] yeah
I mean but I'm not doing anything yeah
you know like yeah but you know how some
women can get real pissy some women do
my wife doesn't my wife I mean look my
wife knows where I'm gonna land every
day no I don't think anyone has any
illusions of me I mean look at me do you
think anyone's [__] hey bro you're a
high volume man you got you're doing
well people love you yeah well I'm up my
wife knows me very well I have intimacy
issues I have uh I have a lot of issues
and my wife knows I'm I'm terrified of
disease like so
I think if I cheated on my wife my
wife's first words would be no [__]
way
really oh yeah there's no way she'd
believe it she'd be like no [__] way
you're so open about your relationship
with her it's great like it makes me
feel like I know you so well yeah like
and that's part of the thing about you
people we we love you because we feel
like there's nothing we don't know about
you well it can be problematic because I
shared I over share yeah everything I I
but I don't know
I don't know the boundaries I just don't
have them you know I was like their
secrets Tom won't tell me because he
knows I'll just tell it like I'll just
tell it I don't have I don't have a
filter but and but not like I don't know
there's I I wish I could dial it back
there's times that like I remember when
I shared Isla's my youngest daughter's
uh period story on Conan and I didn't
run a buyer and yeah and I was like and
then I got home and I was like [__] is
that was that that's gonna upset or
anything I was like he didn't ask her
and I was like no I go it's a great
[__] story though
she's like you might want to tell her
and so I told her I said hey you know
the period party thing she was like yeah
I told him I'll come and it killed she
was like what do you mean you told him
what's Conan you remember the big
redheaded guy you met at Comic-Con she's
like yeah I go that guy I go it's gonna
be on TV tonight you should watch it wow
and she was like it's on TV [__] she's
in like [__] sixth grade and so I
played it and at first
she was like you could tell she was a
little uneasy and then and I was like
I'm like I [__] up as a dad I really
[__] up and I was but it's a good
story and it's got a good heart it's got
It's about a little girl having issues
with going through that period of her
life and then conquering it and and
taking ownership I'm thinking about this
about you because it's a beautiful story
and you come across as so wholesome in
that and it you know but equally if I'm
your family member I'm worried about
being content
yeah you know like because when your
wife came on the cabin when she's
ringing you
like firstly like oh it's his wife I get
to say what his Dynamic is like with her
but then like about five minutes out I'm
like I'm starting to remember all the
stories that you've told about how she
looks when she's sucking your dick and
then I'm realizing like you you got
in-laws oh like you've got children you
thought about that last night yeah well
I mean there's uh the girls now are at
an age where like my last special I just
shot for Netflix they screened it like
they were like and there was one joke
that I really loved and I was like pull
it out I was like for real she goes I
can't be the like that that's between me
and you it's not for the world and I was
like [__] such a good joke it's such a
great parking yeah so I pulled it out
and then I offered her money for it
first but really yeah I was like how
much I go just get out of curiosity is
there a price on it and she was like no
I was like
like twenty thousand dollars she was
like Dad take it out so I pulled it out
um uh but yeah I mean you got you gotta
at least ask right if the kids got a
price so you can't pay the kids
um but there's a disconnect and when
your comic
every I don't know I I never thought
about
I never thought about the people I love
telling stories about them on stage and
then people seeing them from the outside
and knowing them intimately without them
the Isle of point was the first one that
pointed that out to me I said you know I
talk about you a lot this is a secret
time that's how I talk about you a lot
uh in the special are you okay with that
and she goes we're in the pool and she
was must have been in like fifth grade
she goes it's a little late for that Dad
yeah and I was like well I just want to
make sure you know you're okay she goes
I'm fine I know they're jokes and I know
that it's all good and I know you love
me she was my only problem is I don't
like people who don't know me knowing
who I am
and I was like oh I never realized how
valuable anonymity is like especially
when you're a kid to not be the kid
everyone's looking at going that's her
that's the kid that's her dad's Bert you
know and but in La it's a little
different because everyone's got that
dad like everyone there's there's 20 of
them in her class 20 dads that are like
me that you know and there's 20 dads
that got lit up for me too there's 20
dads that got lit up for cancel culture
I mean there's like you know it's really
it's it's complicated there's you know
it's La it's [__] up you know what
about like the wife and not because the
dynamic with her seems quite interesting
like it must be like for her I think how
does she there's a joke that you make
about having an Elvis face when she has
an orgasm
[__] killed me but then I say her on
screen I'm like all I can think of is
This Elvis idea
um
are you guys old-fashioned you kind of
come across as a bit old-fashioned uh
yeah yeah we are yeah pretty meat
potatoes yeah she's like she has she had
rough uh like a rough childhood and so I
think she
fixed that in herself and then when we
met was like oh I'm gonna help you
figure out the tools to fix it in you
but ultimately all she really wanted was
like
I think stability
and you know and all I wanted was I you
know I just said this to someone the
other day I dated girls especially like
in New York and La that uh would look
past you when they talk to you all right
yeah you know like they're just like
seeing who else is in the room like you
know and I never liked that I always I
was social climbers yeah and they and
they were they dating you for the right
reason my wife when I dated her all she
cared about was talking to me and like
she didn't give a [__] if we went out if
we got pizza if we watched a movie she
just wanted to be with me like the idea
that that's it Mom yeah that's when I
landed it's landed Center on my eyes
yeah and I was like oh I could be I
remember thinking like I could be with
this chick for the rest of my life
exactly and then and then I [__] it up
I uh I got into a fight with one of her
friends and on an argument and and uh
and I couldn't ride my boat and I was
still bothered by it and then my wife's
like you know let's take a break and
then the second she said that I went oh
I [__] this up I need that woman back
like that's the one for the rest of my
life she's like the good person the good
person that has no there's no flaws
there she's just good good person when
someone's wanted to give you 100 like
that and also has your best interest at
heart and you come across as a [__]
lunatic sometimes so you need that that
good she will always tell me the right
thing the true thing the trustworthy
person oh and it hurts it hurts a lot
like she's brutally honest with me oh
really like brutally [__] honest I
mean
to a flaw at times I think I want to I
want to be like I've said to her you
know you don't have to tell me the truth
like you can just lie to me and just and
it'll it'll I won't know the difference
adverse like I'll give you an example I
did a show at the Rose Bowl with Tom uh
and Jay Leno it was when I was doing the
outdoor uh outdoor venues now I've done
so many of them at the time during the
pandemic I was doing drive-in movie
theaters if you had never seen one you
have a hard time understanding if it was
good or not does that make sense okay
um because everyone was out it's
outdoors everyone's socially distanced
or by their cars oh yeah so the laughter
isn't like a comedy club yeah but you
could definitely once you did enough of
them you were like that that one
delivered and people had a good time
they were getting out of the house the
what you were offering people was so
much more than just a comedy show it was
an IDE is an idea that they got to get
out especially in La especially all over
the country
so we get we get done the show it's huge
it's like [__] 3 000 cars it's
[__] massive now mind you that's also
like a quarter of a mile back okay
everyone's in their cars
I'm getting a golf cart and drive around
and do like a meet and greet socially
distance meet and greet it's just such
[__] great Jay Leno's there so get in
the car and I said uh I'm like feeling
good I created this thing I've created
this thing this drive-in movie theater
thing it's doing great where everyone's
making money I'm employing a group of 12
dudes I got two bus drivers I got a
whole crew that's putting everyone's got
jobs every show all anyone says to me is
hey Bert thanks for the works remember
this is the pandemic so many [__] I
got merged people that are employed I
got
security guards are employed everyone's
so grateful not to mention the fans who
are getting to have a great moment
Outdoors socially distanced and saved
again the car with Leanne
I go what a night she goes sad excuse
for a comedy show
whoa you know what the [__] is wrong
with you excuse me it's not a comedy
show it's not like a comedy show the way
I know them yeah it's like it's
different but it's just not a comedy
show it's not like like it's and I'm
gonna go hang on stop oh all you had to
say was nothing you could have just said
nothing you know when you're doing your
best as well yeah and her words mean
more to you than anyone else's I went
home and I knew I know she didn't mean
to hurt my feelings I knew it
and I just and I was like it's best if I
don't talk because I know that I'm hurt
and I know you didn't mean to do it yeah
and she was like I and she's like I
don't know why I said it and I was like
because that's how you felt yeah that's
how you felt so you say what you feel
and I said I appreciate you because I'm
just saying like it'll be better when
you can get back in theaters and and and
I mean it's it's great no it's great and
then she's like back pedals like no I
know you said and it's not it's not it's
not the comedy show you know but it's
something it's something that's that's
it's it's a workaround and then and by
the way she's done it so many more times
so many more times where she says the
thing but then like when you when I did
the movie and she came to set and she
watched me act and she goes you can
really act I'm like okay I guess I can
because she would definitely tell me she
would definitely [__] tell me and
when I do my special I just shot my
special in Omaha first show I get off
[__] she was like that wasn't good
and I'm like no no yeah I know I know I
know she goes I'm just saying you got
three more you gotta hit it out of the
park do the second show my murderers
comes out she goes that was the show and
I'm like okay and then and then I
actually go to bed going I got it I got
two more shows I'm good this is gonna be
great I know that I know that she'd tell
me the truth and I you want that it just
hurts
trust is the basis for all good
relationships and you guys have it
clearly we definitely I mean look I know
for a fact she would never never cheat
on me yeah I mean
I say to her all the time
it's because it's I don't know I was
never a guy for my longest relationship
was like five years and I was like can I
can you believe I still love you like I
can isn't that crazy yeah that I look at
you and I still love you like most guys
don't like most guys bail at this point
but I go I still [__] love you yeah
oh they get bored and just stick it out
because the the alternative is
loneliness yeah yeah yeah well I think
for some guys I've watched dudes bail
and I think the I think men get a lot of
[__] for bailing women seem like you go
girl yeah don't yeah you don't need him
yeah but men get [__] when they leave a
a relationship long term right my
buddies are my buddy's a divorced dad
and he's killing it he's killing it oh
is he oh he's killing like hey his
[__] kids on the weekend he just he's
like it goes out he doesn't goes to
Vegas he has a blast and he's like you
know man and he's giving me advice I'm
like the [__] this thing I ever
did bro I love that I'm a divorced dad
kind of because I'm only on I'm on the
road so much I'm home for the weekend
and yeah now George is at college so
Island Leanne are like roommates it's
[__] hilarious I call up and they're
they are like two [__] roommates how
old do they know August 16 George is 18.
okay so they're at that age now I want
to talk to you about that um I was so I
was watching binge watching all your
stuff obviously knowing you're coming on
you were in the woods with Caitlyn
Jenner yeah wow that was a weird watch
like I was I was kind of I could feel
that it was weird yeah it must have been
weird on set for you uh so
uh it wasn't totally weird here's okay
I'll tell you I mean this is what I'm
saying yeah no no I'll tell you all the
behind the scenes stuff huh so I called
my dad that morning and uh and he's like
what are you doing and I'm like are we
getting ready to start shooting Caitlyn
Jenner's coming out and he was like
buddy don't do it don't do it [__]
pull the plug hold the goddamn plug you
guys got I'm telling you right now this
world is too [__] up you're gonna say
the wrong thing I need to get in trouble
You're Gonna Cancel you're gonna lose
your house lose your family everything
you can take it all away and and then he
goes you don't understand who you're
talking to by the way like you're
talking to a Goddamn hero and I was like
what and he was like she's using the
right pronouns he's like she was the
decathlon champ I mean you don't
understand I sat with you on the
Montreal Olympics in 72 I sat with you
as a baby on my lap watching her just
maybe the 74 Olympics watching or
whatever he goes uh he goes I just quit
track and field I just focused on my
life I was I just got my law degree I
was trying to make my something in my
life and I watched her she's an American
[__] hero cancel it you don't wanna
you'll [__] this up so I was like
I'm not canceling it she's on her way so
I hang up with my dad Nikki Glazer shows
up yeah I'm in the I think I'm in the
middle of waxing my ass with Fortune
Fortune leaves Nikki comes in she pulls
it she's greeted by your butthole yeah
she's greeted by my butthole and so uh I
could not be a better person to see my
butthole oh commitment she gets such as
such a good sense of humor and
especially the all of me too [__] that's
going on and I got tired I'm like Nikki
do you consent uh so uh man Caitlyn
Jenner's walking up the stairs like 60
seconds later as this girl's waxing your
[__] I was like what the [__] am I
watching this is Mendel this is the best
part so like Caitlyn shows up Nikki
shows up and then we we kind of stop
down for a second you know everyone get
mics on and whatnot
and Nikki pulls me aside and she goes
you didn't tell me Caitlyn Jenner was
going to be here and I was like I didn't
and she was like Bert
I went on Stern the day after the roast
they said there when she roasted Caitlyn
she goes and there were like 20 jokes I
had written that I submitted and they
said you cannot tell these if you tell
them Caitlyn will walk off she goes I
went on Stern the next day and told all
of them
she goes this could be bad and I'm like
[__] so the whole time I'm
watching Caitlin Nicky like waiting for
Caitlyn and but Caitlyn was cool as
[__] [__] I almost killed her oh yeah
you know what's so funny
for those who haven't seen it you spun
an axed towards the the dart board at
the wrong angle and it [__] bounced
back over I could have [__] taken
your head off oh it was uh
but then but then we're all sitting
there and my dad [__] calls me and
I'm like oh and we have and like I think
that's the beauty of that show at least
is and it's a beauty of podcasting also
and I think the reason that show was
successful and I think you'll see this
is that it technically was just a
podcast yeah technically just a podcast
where you did [__] yeah I mean I mean
and and you literally shot at one point
when Bobby Lee shoved the tube up your
ass yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I shot I shot
I shot all over the place yeah but it's
but my when we casted it so when we were
looking to have people come out yeah
they were looking for like big names
celebrities and I was like I was like
Bobby Lee's great and they're like okay
Bobby Lee and I was like yeah Bobby Lee
and Donnell would be great Nikki's great
Fortune's great miss Pat's awesome and
like I Joey Tom oh I was like all these
guys you don't have to cue them all you
have to do is say we're rolling and then
they'll just talk like Joey Diaz we have
[__] possibly
eight hours of gold of Tom and I were
crying laughing by the end of that we
were CR we were like I'm dehydrated I've
been laughing so hard and so that was
the beauty of that shows you just let
him go and then and everyone talked and
then with my dad and Caitlin we had this
great moment where my dad started crying
and said to Caitlin you don't understand
you're my hero and you're an American
hero thank you so much for everything
and it was really [__] insane it was
a great show it's Caitlyn she's like you
had a lovely little moment after that
where you were like I've never seen my
dad like that before and I think that
you what really comes across about you
and your dad's relationship is how
different you are like you the guy was a
lawyer you're a comedian like God knows
what he was thinking watching you on the
come up thing and this is my son like
this guy is nothing like me it must have
been a weird time I think so my dad had
a mentality his mentality was eat [__]
cash checks that's his mentality
is you could be digging ditches remember
that anything
you should cash checks that was his
motto
and uh I mean gave me a great break-off
speech when I was 26 and I moved to New
York and I thought I was making it and
on my birthday
uh I was like [__] partying and I
wasn't doing stand-up and we called me
on my 26th birthday and he was like I
was like I was like oh he's just calling
to say happy birthday I'll just answer
it and he was like I go alone he goes
you are a tremendous piece of [__] I was
like what he goes you're an
embarrassment I just perjured myself in
court the judge just said how's your son
doing and I said great he was I've never
lied in court I just perjured myself in
court what I should have said is he has
no humility or honor he has no ability
to get anything he doesn't he thinks
he's better than everyone else your
honor and like gave me this huge
break-off speech and then got me
ultimately into stand up because of that
because he was like you need to do
whatever
and you do what no one else will do to
get on stage you tell them you'll mop up
you'll make burgers you'll you go to
that club and do it and I went and
didn't work right away the first night
the guy told me to go [__] myself call
my dad and he goes great that's how life
works that's how life works it's called
adversity and he goes now you go back
the next night tonight you go back again
tonight
and you tell them the same thing and
you're gonna tell him that when he tells
you to [__] yourself you'll see him
tomorrow night and you're gonna go every
[__] night until he gives you an
opportunity and that's how life works
that's what a man who wants something
does and so I did it and then the second
night the guy was like are you being
serious I go look man here's the deal
yesterday was my birthday my dad told me
I didn't deserve a party like I was like
I was like this is my dad hates me right
now and I and I I I'm gonna be coming
every [__] night because my dad told
me to until you give me an opportunity
and the guy's like
all right if you bring in 25 people by
the end of the night I'll let you go on
last and I was like for real and it
worked and then I got to stand up six
months later Will Smith discovered me
and then and and the rest is history and
my now now my dad had taught me humility
uh all these great things that like e
[__] cash checks so I started working
for Travel Channel I'd worked the road I
never like whenever they lowered our
rates on the road I'd accept it and I
didn't fight it I didn't have an ego
about anything I was like a good
employee I was like a like just like a
[__] earner you know and I had a
family and then
towards the end of my travel channel
career
um Rogan and Burr have pulled me aside
and said your TV show sucks like it's
horrible like you're a much better comic
than you are on this show it's not who
you are you should quit that show focus
on your podcast focus on uh stand up I
remember them saying what's your nut
like what do you got to make a year to
like keep your family afloat and I told
them and they're like
yeah we can help you get that like we'll
just get you and we'll help you get ad
sales we'll help you we'll come in your
podcast we'll boost your numbers and
then we'll get your numbers up we'll get
everyone to come on your podcast we'll
help you out and then uh and then we'll
get you that and what is it like to have
friends do that for you though like
that's that's so special like ain't no
one done that for me I've done that for
other people ironically and they haven't
been very good about it afterwards you
know I mean so you know that's that's
life-changing I remember them I mean Tom
was I mean I say this in all seriousness
Tom was probably the most integral
person in getting that done because
whereas you know Bill and Joe would Joe
would put me on I'm doing Joe's podcast
I don't even know how many times
millions of times yeah he put me on if I
had anything he put me on I remember
doing it back to back days at times yeah
and doing five and a half hours and him
just glowing and saying nice things when
I wasn't on there oh I love his body
whatever
Tom was the most integral Tom was very
specific and he was like we need to get
you to 50 000 downloads per episode if
you can get a 50 000 then get you
fifteen hundred dollars and I can set
you up with an ad sales person and then
you introduce me the ad sales people who
I'm still with to this day and
and he's like you got to get to 50 and
get like keep it at 50. it's got to be
always at 50.
and he gave me so much great advice and
then got me there and then once I got
there I it just kept growing I I don't
know if I mean I I couldn't even I would
not be in this business without those um
more than that Joey Diaz
Ari you know I mean I I already and I I
mean I know everyone thinks Ari and I
have passed [__] you know but for those
who don't know he did drug you he
drugged me in my backyard but yeah my
daughter in the Isla was like I was like
you need to I watched that episode as it
was happening and I remember because I'm
like super fun of all you guys and I was
like what the [__] are we watching here
this it's it took like a turn and it was
way more serious than we'd ever seen
before because it's like this wholesome
group of mates and then one of them's
like yeah I drugged them with Molly uh
before a flight or it was a flight right
yeah and this was when you're with your
family yeah and I remember looking at
Tom segura's face and he was looking at
like he looked Furious Tom was pretty
Furious yeah Tom was pretty Furious
because Usher can really do people in
yeah Thomas Furious Joe was Joe didn't
really understand what was going on yeah
it was until a couple days later that
Joe was like
I was like wait what the [__] happened
like what like he called me because I
went on the road
my serotonin was gone so I'm like having
panic attacks on the road but um and
then we and then you know we figured it
out we're friends and where we figured
it out how did you figure out because
that's Psych I mean like your wife and
kids must have been like [__] they
hate him yeah they hate them with my
daughter I was I remember maybe a year
two years after that I'm sitting at
dinner with my family my my mom and dad
and sisters and that my phone's like
this and I get a text from Ari and I
look at it and my daughter Georgia grabs
it and goes absolutely not and pulls my
phone away all right you will not be
texting him back especially when I'm not
here when I'm here and I was like okay
Leanne hates him Leon never forgive him
um George and Ila said to me you know
the other day she goes I think you
really need to reassess your friendships
at times dad and I was like what do you
mean she goes your best friend just gave
you Nazi memorabilia for your birthday
and then your other friend drugged you
in our backyard she goes dad like if
they're if I had friends like that what
would you say and I was like it's it's
complicated Island it's complicated but
the truth is is that
arya's a really special person to me and
he always has been and he is someone
like I said like when you look at like
Tom him Joe all my friends I I wouldn't
be where I am because I there's like so
much [__] that that's in the weeds that
I can't even that you'll never even like
tell him especially and I have to say
this but it's like I remember telling
Tom I was sold out helium in Philly and
he was like
he was like how much your ticket prices
and I said 20. and he goes you got to
bump out up to 35 and I was like what
and he's like trust me get it up to 35
and then once you can sell that at 35
Bert it's all [__] skating from there
and I went and I remember I just there's
like he doesn't know what he's talking
about I've been doing this longer than
him he doesn't know what he's talking
about and then he got up to 35 and Tom's
like just so you know you don't have to
be in that club anymore you can go do
the truck he gives it 600 seats and
you'll fill out the whole weekend at the
truck next time I went to Philly I did
the truck I did I think I did six shows
and I was like how did you know that and
he's like because he'd already been
there Joe's already been there bill has
already been there they've already
walked once you see once you've been
through that path in the woods it's
super easy to shout from the woods and
go over here they seem to give you the
confidence and when I watch you talk
interrupt with them you seem less sure
of yourself yeah than what they are yeah
you seem a little more
um I don't know I think it's fair to say
mentally you seem a little younger than
them I always feel younger
yeah and they're like come on let's do
this well you gotta remember I didn't
get success until I was like 44 45. like
I mean bill I mean you I'm I won't
Bill's a bad example but like Joe
Joe's been successful his whole [__]
career he's been successful since he was
like 27. yeah Tom has been successful at
a way younger age than me so like so
like I kind of you know I was a great
I'm not that way on stage but as a man
is like I I look up to my friends I
surround myself with dudes better than
me I think that's like a I don't know I
don't know if it's because I'm I'm
insecure or whatever but I'm don't
really hang out with people that aren't
better than me like I I [__] with dudes
that do it at the next level and so I
always hook up to them Lucy cam I mean
lose a friend of mine we text back and
forth but like I definitely look up to
Louis I really look up to Louis like and
even big Jay oakerson I look up to Big
Jay Louise Luis J Gomez Luis Gomez is
doing amazing things with Legion of
skanks and I'll I I've never been the
guy to tell you let me tell you how it
works because I don't know how it works
I like being around guys and then going
like so what do you think yeah like I
love that I love that I texted Joe I was
texting with Joe last night about
[__] Pierce Morgan
um because I was like I don't know I
don't know anything about Piers Morgan I
mean he's a [__] yeah so this
um but uh Rogan watching like the
successful what he was and then the
successful where he is now what was it
like as his friend watching him become
the center of attention in America where
all of a sudden people are really
threatened by what he's become like the
the king of the dudes yeah
it's uh I don't know it's a it's a very
it's a very full suitcase of a question
in that
I so
because he was getting canceled weekly
probably yeah it's so funny one of his
cancels one of the times he was getting
canceled pretty hard he called me and I
and uh this kind of guy Joe is and I
complained to him about something going
on in my life
that's so you by the way honestly and
then halfway through I was like oh [__]
man how are you doing
he seems so like he he's man I don't
know he's a different he's a different
dude he never seems phased by what is
going on not at all because
he is the most curious human being I've
ever met my entire life he is genuinely
the most curious man I've ever person
I've ever met
um he is the best friend you could ever
ask for I mean to the point where it's
like
you can't say things you want around him
because he'll show up at your [__]
house oh okay like that like legit
you learn that and then there's dudes
that see it and then they ask for it and
you're like oh [__] those guys Joe's but
that's who Joe is he's generous I don't
I I remember one time I was at Madison
Square Garden and he was in Madison
Square Garden he was doing the UFC and I
was doing they have a like a 5 000 seat
theater there and so I was doing the
theater
two shows and uh and Joe's in the
[__] Arena and I wanted to go watch
the fights so I text Joe and I was like
hey man I don't like are you here
because I'm here I'm at the thing and he
was like dude [__] yeah let me know and
immediately I was like
um I'm gonna buy tickets right now
because I'm not because I know Joe well
who's getting ready for work will
[__] be like let me get you tickets
hang on we gotta get birth tickets and
so I'm [__] real quick I was like
someone buy us 10 tickets can't just buy
them right now so that when he texts
back I can tell them I already have him
and he was like what do you need and I
was like got him I already got him and
he was like oh tell me if you need any
more and I was like I'm good thank you
brother like immediately that's who he
is you know when you talk about being
curious yeah I think that that's what
makes him such a great podcaster because
if you look at him five years ago he's a
different person because he's absorbing
information at a rate that's like
remember that Batman movie where the
riddle is absorbing all the knowledge
yeah he's like that in podcasts like he
just takes so much on board I don't know
how he does it I don't know how he does
it I listen to him and Jordan Peterson
the other day and I'm just like I'll
never have Jordan Peterson on my podcast
I don't know what the [__] say to them
I've had him on and it's like you have
to pin him down sometimes like he's all
over yeah but I was like Joe is he is
just an amazing guy what's interesting
the interesting thing about Joe is I
remember watching his podcast blow up
and watching it in his amazement because
I don't think he saw it happening so
remember we were there we were there
when it was flashlights oh yeah we were
all there and went at his house his kids
would be running around his wife would
be chasing his kids yeah you'd be
[__] you'd go to the back backyard
and smoke a joint
going to his office his phone landline
would ring he had phones in his house
yeah and then he'd be like grab a
flashlight then you'd leave and it was
like I remember watching him going like
he's like hey man
are you getting hit up online a lot and
I was like I don't know and he's like
what is where's your Instagram or your
Twitter going and I was like yeah it's
blowing up and he was like yeah man a
lot of people listen to that episode
like really like I remember watching him
say it like hey did you book too well
and I'm like yeah why because you're I
mean are you selling tickets because
like when when I have you on you're not
like these numbers are like crazy and
then he would like I could you'd see in
his eyes I won't say I won't say real
numbers but he's like
an episode got 10 million listens and
you're like what the [__] I remember him
talking about ad reads and he was like
tell me his number per ad read and I was
like
when you when you talk for one minute
that's what you get yeah and he was like
I know right like but you could watch
the amazement in his eyes I was with him
the other day uh and we were in we were
in Texas getting stem cells and uh with
my parents oddly enough and so we get in
this car
in his truck and I go uh
I go hey man what's the difference
between like
10 million and like 350 million
and he looks up and he goes
I don't worry much
he doesn't seem motivated by that
I think that's why he's the perfect King
yeah because he doesn't really want to
be that you know what I mean like and
he's a reluctant like he's not the
flashy guy like he's got Conor McGregor
money but you would never know it you'd
never know he doesn't he's not a flashy
guy he wears the same [__]
same shirts that he gets for free from
[__] from people say he's in he's
this he is the regular guy he texts you
back immediately if you call he answers
um he's not do you think he's worried
about people or trying now now that he's
become the Noah like everyone knows what
he is now
he must have to keep people at arm's
length who are trying to be those you
know leeches he has the best radar for
that yeah he has the
he has such good radar that he'll tell
you hey just a heads up you got a
vampire on your left and you're like for
real and he's like big time you need to
get the [__] away from that guy you need
to get the [__] away from him right now
and he'll he's so good at recognizing
I mean he's done it he's done it so many
times where I'm like remember this I
don't I want to go because the guy will
know more talking about him but like I
remember one guy was just
coming up I was like hey man Hey Joe
it's good to see you and Joe's like I'm
talking to Bert all right yeah and he's
like no no it's uh it's like hey man we
should podcast sometimes he's like hey
man I'm talking to Bert and the guy's
like all right I'll give you a call and
Joe I remember Joe look at me because
you know my number and he goes well give
it to me because I'm not giving you my
number leave me alone and I was like
what he's like this guy's a [__] and
you're like and I remember watching this
and going like
I get that impression as well like uh I
mean he's the absolute inspiration for
me the whole time like he's an
inspiration for all of us I mean he's
dude there's so many things he's he's
such
he's such a like a channel marker
on so many things on on longevity On
Wellness on on I mean uh just though his
work ethic the way he he drives his own
pirate ship he does his own things you
look at his business model and I I try
to say this to my my team all the time
this business model is him and Jamie
amazing that's it it's him and Jamie and
then a couple other guys that are you
know help out and then he's got some
security guys with him but pretty much
he's streamlined he's been with the same
manager for his entire career his his
team that he works internally with are
all I mean all amazing human beings and
so he kind of keeps it very insular and
and he's an inspiration for everyone you
know you look at like Tom when you go to
Tom Tom's got like
25 employees 27 employees he's you know
he's got a big [__] studio and and
but that's the way Tom lives his life
Tom's a little more like throw money at
it let's see how big it'll get let's see
how big it'll get Joe's really like
Whittle it down to what it is me talking
to one another person how do we get that
out to as many people
and like Tom's like I want to build a I
want to build a brand I want to build I
mean Tom's a great business partner
trust me when I say that a great
business partner because tonight we have
we have a conference call about about
[__] two bears racing because I we
know I bought him a race car and we've
been trying to build this race team but
he's been on the road and now he's
getting time off and now we're building
a race team wow and and but Tom's the
guy that goes let's do it let's do it
let's get this let's do this thing yeah
we'll build it there we'll meet our
contacts we'll take meetings we'll Tom
that's how Tom's brain works I do feel
like Tom's moving in a a really Forward
Thinking Direction with his studio and
yeah like how you've got multiple
podcasts on a network and I like the way
he's thinking I wish I had fought that
way yeah I wish I'd like when we started
two bears I wish I was like let's start
our own YouTube channel but you know
it's it's his it's in all honesty
I I wouldn't have the wherewithal to to
do what we did what he did with two with
two bears I mean you know granted we're
Partners but
I'm more I would say Tom would say this
is I'm more of a
kind of shoot shoot throw rocks at the
Moon creative partner and he's more of a
let's stay grounded in reality and get
[__] done partner so like I would have
never been able to build two bears the
way we've built it without him without
and I don't think
I don't think I could have done what
he's done what do you like with money
generally I'm [__] cheap yeah yeah I
mean I'm not
I get
I I don't I don't I have a problem
spending money like I just have a
problem because I I just feel like it's
better to have it and save it and I
don't need nice things so like I don't I
know I have a I know I have a nice car
but I don't know exactly what car I have
and I know people have told me what it
is it's like the bigger Mercedes okay
but I just Tom hit me up with his car
guy and I forget his name right now but
he's a nice guy and he's like
what do you tell them what you want I
was like I don't even know what I want
like send me some options you guys sent
me a couple options I liked one I liked
white and I liked the interior that's
all I knew I like that it's a chocolate
interior I thought I feel like cool like
a cool older man I like that and so uh I
got it but someone's always like what
car do you have I remember Bernie shops
like what kind of Mercedes you have it's
like I have no [__] idea
um I don't like my wife doesn't have a
problem spending money you know funny
little thing yeah she just bought this
house to build this podcast studio and
she is building it out so it looks
amazing all I see is a [__] money
hemorrhaging out yeah that's all I see
that's all I find you're a hard worker
though that's one thing you definitely
got from your father yeah hard worker a
very hard I mean like I did I just work
as much as I can because I I mean I it's
like I remember when people didn't want
to me to work like no one gave a [__]
yeah because getting successful at 44
you said 44. so six years ago I posted
the machine story on on on uh Facebook
yeah and uh yeah so 44 44 43
yeah 44 is when I started selling
tickets does that make you feel like you
haven't like you have to maximize it and
just work your balls off now yeah yeah
yeah I mean I always feel like it's
going away like I just looked at my
ticket sales for uh
I I like I'm weird I won't open bills
and stuff like I don't look at bills I
don't look at [__] mail and like I
don't open emails with emails yeah and
so I get it's like getting infected with
it you can't be funny when that you're
stressed I agree yeah 100 people I I try
to explain this to people around me I'm
like I need you to just do this yeah
because if I start getting clogged up
with that I ain't gonna be able to be
the best me on camera yeah and I I
operate I'm a very like soft spirit and
so um you are my very soft I'm very soft
and so very I mean if I had a nickel for
every time Tom tried to talk me off a
ledge of getting my feelings hurt by
people you'd be but that's what makes
you like lovable like that's what I like
about you you come across as the softest
friendliest guy in that group and I
think that that's what people
you know like we we have an idea of what
you guys are like off camera and that's
how you come across oh well thank you
yeah I hope that's good the uh
I get I was saying I get ticket sales
ticket sales every day they send them to
me and I never look at them I never look
at them they always they're always okay
but like I never want to know like
I never want to stress and so like I
start my tour my American tour this
Thursday
in or Wednesday in Williamsport
um
and so I was like [__] I was like I
gotta look at ticket sales I'm doing the
Boston Garden there are TD Gardens in
Boston
I'm like I'm like what let's take a look
at that see how many tickets are gonna
sell still I got to do Bangor Maine I'm
doing an arena there I'm doing all
arenas this this next 220 2023.
and then I'll look and I was like oh I'm
sold out I sold out the garden okay cool
and then I was like oh I sold out Bangor
oh I sold out Hershey oh I got I added a
second show in Williamsport and I was
like oh [__] then I'm like oh I'm almost
sold out in Tampa I'm sold out in
Orlando and then I'm like I have nothing
to worry about okay I can start looking
at these ticket sales now but like
that's how my brain works I always think
my career is about to end um I'm the
same I I think uh for me it comes from
having money worries as a younger person
yeah I was so used to distressing and
worrying about money that I always think
it's gonna get worse uh so you kind of
have to train yourself out with that but
I know you like I have I've had
depression issues in the past you've
talked about anxiety or OCD yeah
um what what is it that makes you have
that do you think in you like is there
well they say they say it's they say it
comes from something from trauma or
something I was always afraid of
tornadoes as a kid like I was really
weather freaked me out yeah because I
grew up in Florida and so like
thunderstorms lightning I mean I was I
have such a real fear of lightning you
have no idea like I shut down really if
oh I can't be outside I can't be outside
I I would say most kids in Florida are
like that but like I can't be outside in
lightning at all
um I can't be around like in New York if
there's lightning and I'm in a building
I'm terrified some I know I'm right
there like I and you're not in control
that's why I also don't like flying yeah
but yeah my anxiety my anxiety has
gotten
uh better I think it was really bad when
I was a kid and I didn't even know I had
it um do you think that was what spoke
on the pot even drinking and stuff well
I didn't start drinking really until I
was 22. like I mean I drank a little bit
and we partied as kids you know like
beers but I'm really focused on baseball
so I never really like partied much
and then uh
and then at 22 and I went to Russia uh
that's when I was and this sounds I mean
it sounds
staged a little bit but like when I met
the mafia and I started partying with
those guys that's when I was like I
would just drink with them and I was I
could make everyone laugh and we had a
language barrier and I was like oh yeah
and then when I came back from Russia I
remember thinking all right I'm gonna
slow it down because I'd party it all
through Europe I didn't have any money
on I would get I would just party and I
was just and I was like the life of the
party and I was like this is what I'm
realizing oh maybe I should do comedy
like I'm pretty funny and then I come
home and my chick
that I was uh dating
um cheated on me with my best friend and
it [__] and I remember I remember
that's when I leaned into drinking and I
was like I was like I mean I'll do it
yeah and I was like I was dating for
five years then then all of a sudden and
everyone knew so like all of a sudden
I'm this like Town cuck you know like
everyone knew because I was in Russia
and they were like dating in Tallahassee
and so it [__] me up and I started
partying to kind of like almost like I
was afraid people were looking at me
like going like I feel so bad for that
oh so if you look like you're having the
best time No One's Gonna Love You that
way yeah I think and and
and I and then I remember being like
dating not not having sex with but
dating really hot women like hooking up
with them I wouldn't I wouldn't have I
remember there was this
absolutely
beautiful check
and uh I spent the night at her house we
didn't have sex
she woke up naked the next day like we
fooled around but we didn't have sex
naked the next she got out of bed and
she was perfect
this is how [__] up my brain is and I
said I need to get away from her because
she's perfect and she doesn't want to
she I don't want to ruin her with
something broken like me oh wow and I
was like I'm just [__] broken like I
remember thinking her body's perfect I
want to let her have her great life I
remember thinking that
and then never calling her again so
unusual for a young man to say that
though right because like normally
you know I mean you even said when your
wife met you she was trying to help fix
you yeah um oh when when Leanne got to
me she was like first thing he said is
you're misogynistic you need to know
that I was like no I mean she goes no
you are and we're gonna fix that don't
worry don't worry you have two strong
sisters a great mom and me what what
would make there's something and it was
being cheated on I just didn't trust
women I didn't trust them I didn't like
them I just thought they're all I
remember telling I mean Liam will tell
you this too but and I've said it before
but I didn't want to go out on Leanne I
didn't want to go on a date with Ian
because I thought she was a [__] she's
like why you don't even know me and I
said no but why would you want to date
me like if you want to date me you must
I mean I had I swear your self-esteem
was oh my
I was like all women just want to sleep
with men and they don't care about
feelings because I was like I was always
wanting to fall in love like I mean I
just I go to bars and I just want to I'd
be like I hope someone understands me
like I hope someone gets me wow I hope
someone's like I hope someone says to me
do you want to just go back to your
house and watch Fletch and get a pizza
and I'd be like yes and so I think a lot
of people have these thoughts but they
don't they don't say it like you're
saying it right now maybe I don't know I
know I know I definitely had them and uh
and I and I I mean I was like I and and
Leanne put all the people I mean I I
remember when I went to New York
I moved to New York and I was I dated a
chick in Tallahassee and we broke up and
I had a hard time not calling her I
didn't have a cell phone at the time but
I had a landline I was living in New
York I was about to get a cell phone but
I did not have it yet and I remember
I no one had my number but her and my
parents and I I remember unplugging my
phone and going I'm going to take this
Band-Aid off the hard way I'm gonna get
over this chick and then I'm gonna fix
myself so that I believe I can deserve a
chick like because I'm gonna I'm gonna
be single but I remember thinking the
only way I deserve a chick is if I have
money and I have success in career so I
just stayed away I mean why it's the
only reason I've I haven't had sex with
a lot of people is because I literally
had what two three girlfriends my entire
life and then I stayed away from women
just goes focus on my career focus on my
career focus on my career focus on my
career and then
and then a couple more and then I met
Leanne that's really healthy though not
enough men do that like a lot a lot of
bum men out there just try and latch
onto a woman and hope that they carry
them or like they don't realize that you
have to be proud of who you are before a
woman's kind of value you at all I would
say things to myself like and this is so
[__] up I would say to myself uh right
before I met Leanne I said I wouldn't
date the woman that would date me right
now I didn't like me and I was like I'm
overweight I don't have my [__] together
I said I want to get myself so that so
that all the [__] numbers are up like
that I look good I remember going I
still have my hair my teeth are okay
like I just need to lose some weight I
have some money I have some money like
just get all these things up get all
these things up and then and be healthy
and like and I got all the things up I
mean you can find the picture of me when
I met Leanne I'm Type in skinny Bert I'm
like I look good I'm going I have I have
a great house I have a great car I'm
working I'm doing stand up
my teeth are in my mouth my hair is
still on and I mean all this is working
for me and then I met Leanne and I was
like I remember I was like I met her at
like
like I'm talking fight day weight like
just [__] ready to go I've been
eating clean for 13 weeks like and so
but I remember thinking that like I want
to I want to get to there so I can find
the girl
forever and then I'll I'm like I'm good
I'll put my mouth what were you looking
for in women like when you were in those
young years like like that girl
I was looking for I was looking for a
blonde a big tits tan I mean it was all
it was all exterior stuff really oh yeah
yeah yeah oh any personality Trace I
didn't know they had them literally I
didn't know for what were they gonna
talk to me I don't know I was a [__]
idiot I was like I want them to look
good I want him to uh I want to be
attracted sexually attracted some my dad
cheated on my mom uh when I was in
college and
I remember thinking uh maybe it's
because she gained weight like that's
why she did it so I was like I was like
so I don't I want to make sure that I'm
physically attracted to the person he
said that no I I thought it Oh I thought
it yeah and I was like I'm gonna I want
to be really physically attracted to the
person that way you'll never cheat on
them I didn't realize that there were
other facets of a relationship that
wouldn't I mean if Leanne was here she
could light me up so [__] hard so
[__] hard of horrible things I would
say to her at times like oh my God I
remember we were taking a hike one time
and I saw a couple walking down and the
girl was overweight and the guy was
skinny and he was in great shape and I
said just giving you a heads up if you
ever get fat I'll cheat on you and she
was like
what the [__] did you just say and I was
like just give me a heads up that's how
it works and she was like all right just
so you know you're fatter than I am I
was like I'm just giving you a heads up
and so like that's where my brand my
brain worked and and I think Leanne had
to get get me out of it and get me out
of my own way of like old stereotypes
old tropes of of what I thought
relationships were I thought everything
was physical I didn't understand about
like I didn't understand
a lot of things I wanted the hottest
chick in the room
I wanted perfect body if I saw flaws I
would [__] fall apart really yeah so
you're a real shallow very shallow by
just very shallow
but young men are you know what I mean
like all you might not do you think in a
relationship there's a responsibility to
sort of maintain your physical in the
long term because now you're in your
like were you 50 now you just I just
turned 50 yeah yeah congrats okay so
you're in like you're in decent shape
for what everyone says like you you have
a bit of 265 yesterday really yeah
that's 260. yeah I see you work out so
yeah you look after yourself do you
think that that's helped like that to
maintain the relationship so yes and but
I don't think it matters
this is gonna be crazy because Leanne
lost a ton of weight and I didn't like
what she looked like skinny oh yeah you
said that oh yeah I heard you say you
kind of preferred a thick a little bit
and I'm never that's not who I am and
ever ever been ever been but I remember
saying to her I liked her with a little
bit of weight on her it just was her
body was better like it was just like I
I don't know it's hard to explain so but
I do like her working out she works out
every day roughly with a trainer her and
her best friend Sandy do and
the what I love about that is number one
I work out and lift weights so that I
don't age and I can get out of chairs at
70. that's why I'm doing it really
honestly I don't give a [__] about I
mean
like I like lifting weights I enjoy
lifting weights but I'm doing it so that
I can stay healthy as I get older
um and and avoid injury I think that's
all ultimately why I'm doing it but for
me it rides my boat mentally and I think
it writes my Leanne's boat mentally and
I think it makes you a happier person
yeah I mean I said when I did the
machine uh I ran four miles every
morning every morning I ran four miles
through this park called Hyde Park in
Serbia every right by Tito's house every
day and every day I didn't want to do it
every day I was hungover and I was like
this isn't I just want to sleep but if I
got up and had a couple coffees and I'd
walk up the hill to get to the top of
the hill and then when I got to stop the
hill if I jog down I could run four
miles and it was all roughly downhill I
know that sounds crazy but the way that
Park set up it's like tilted this way so
your uphill is very short so you'd
Sprint your uphills but then you had a
soft jog
and then every morning I get in the car
and get ready to go to work and go I
feel [__] amazing to think I woke up
at like a six and to know that I'm at a
10 right now that's and that happens to
me every time I never want to work out I
never want to work out but the second I
work out I feel [__] amazing when I'm
done you mentioned the machine I've seen
the trailer yeah loved it thank you and
it is the perfect way to carry on that
story
um you you really good in what I see and
obviously we've seen the trailer you're
a natural uh what was it like to take
that story on all those years later uh
uh it was it was it was there was so
many levels of it very emotional oddly
enough
um because you know it's a story I've
told on stage now for probably 10 years
and uh and I'm known for and the day we
started filming was the same day I flew
to Russia and the same day I started
Florida State
Florida state was on that same day and
then the day I moved I flew to Russia
was on the same day all these things
happened in that same period And I was
like oh this is a good week for me and
so
um I mean I would I would find myself
getting emotional I loved the process I
loved all of it I had so much fun doing
it never thought I ever wanted to act my
entire life ever and I was vocal about
that don't send me out for auditions I
don't want to be in movies I don't give
a [__] and then I came back and I was
like I want to do everything I want to
do it all I want to work with Jonah
you're really good oh well thank you but
um I loved it I loved the process it was
very emotional because it is a true
story and so
I mean there's a scene where
there's a scene where I'm acting with
another person who's a was a real person
in my life
and uh and the
such a good actor I just start crying
and they're like dog great emotion I was
like this is very [__] real like I'm
like I'm I remember Mark Hamill and I
have a moment he's your dad and he plays
my dad yeah we have a moment where he's
telling me he's proud of me and I just
start bawling crying and everyone's like
the close-up was on Mark Bert I
appreciate you being committed to the
bip we need you to do that again and I
was like don't worry you there's a
moment I mean there I like I don't want
to give too much of the movie away but
there's a moment where I talk about
being a dad and being the machine and
being losing myself in like a really
very real moment a real moment and I had
to do this scene probably like I don't
know maybe 10 12 times and I cried
genuinely every time an authentic set of
tears that were I mean and it was like
the coolest [__] scene but it's like
it and so like there's it's it's such a
great movie because so many different
levels to it it's funny as [__] [__]
but it's emotional and it's a thriller
and it's a [__] mystery it's like
there's so many it's like the coolest
[__] movie I that Peter atencio's did
an amazing job the people at legendary
are [__] amazing and I'm I'm in love
with everyone at Sony for Distributing
it so when I watch you like you talk
about uh OCD and stuff like that and I
think like how do you on a on a bad day
go out and give people that but oh so it
but it's interesting uh I had
I I can't remember is what was the day
that I was like really sick
and I was we were on we were just here
we were just on tour we were maybe like
Stockholm or maybe Greece maybe Berlin I
forget where it was but I was really
genuine it was Berlin I was genuinely
sick I'd been sick then I got food
poison the night before and I was on the
plane and I couldn't drink on the plane
I was just felt like [__] had anxiety
get to the hotel have a little bit of a
nap but I still feel like [__] go to the
club I'm like uh the second I get on
stage
I am physically 100 I feel no sickness I
start drinking beers and it went away
immediately I mean
I can
I I am I don't I don't spend time in
comments right like because because I
it'll it'll it'll [__] me up so I hired
a team I hired a team to they post
everything for me I shoot all the my own
content and I'll mess around like I'll
post some stuff on Twitter that's fun
but like I I set it up on my phone so I
can't read Twitter so I made the print
so small that I can't read it so that
way I don't read comments but I'll send
stuff like like fun stuff like top five
comedy movies because I like stuff like
I like interactive stuff like that
um but like I I remember one time this
was years ago I got a comment that was
like the guy [__] nailed me and I was
like and it [__] me up and I was like
I was stuck in this place for like a day
and then Leanne comes back and she was
like are you still thinking about
that [__] person isn't thinking about
you they've left that comment and walked
away and now you're sitting with it I
was like yeah I know she was like honey
you need to go get on stage I went to
the store got on stage
gone forever like and it's and it's
crazy my anxiety disappears when I go on
stage and when I do a podcast or when I
put on my Instagram stories like when I
the second I'm on
camera everything kind of Fades away and
I'm like and I I'm a little more genuine
to who I am doesn't it matter how
comedians especially I like that mode
like you took Robin Williams and people
like that who had all this [__] going on
in their Darkness but then you would
never have known I had uh so we were in
my first open water dive was at 90 feet
um I used to be a diver oh for real yeah
my job before this oh what were you like
doing like uh deep sea diving we're
doing welding and stuff yeah yeah with
the helmet and everything yeah yeah oh
that's fine I got one of the helmets
over there behind the camera yeah oh I
couldn't do that I couldn't do that I uh
so our first open water dive we do we do
we did a couple of Open Water Dives like
but there were more training lessons at
a shallower depth and then our first
like legit dive is at 90 feet and I have
deep enough that you'll be aware of how
[__] scary it can be yeah yeah deep
enough that you can't just go up yeah
that's the thing yeah
so it's it's thundering and lightning
right we're in a tin boat we're in like
a steel boat yeah in Fiji oh [__] and
you won't see the beginning this the top
of the boat shows up at 40 feet and the
like the the yeah yeah the map from
visibility yeah visibility so I get in
the water everyone gets in the water and
immediately I'm like everyone starts to
descend on their own I go are we all
going to do this together as a team like
are we gonna hold hands to do it like
who the [__] is everyone going and
everyone I'm just looking everyone no
one seems like they're anywhere else
yeah they're bombing it down yeah and I
start to descend
and have a Moment of clarity where I
realize this isn't what I want like I
don't want to nothing I want is down
there everything I want is upstairs
pizzas beer all the stuff I want is
above the water nothing at once below
the water yeah and so I start coming
back up and my uh my instructor is very
sweet uh Fijian woman just comes over
and goes you okay okay and I was like
yeah so I'm having a little bit of panic
and she goes just breathe and then grabs
my BC and starts deflating me and we
start sinking and I start having a legit
like legit panic attack like like oh
yeah like hardcore everything comes in
I'm I'm panicking breathing and my
cameraman John mans who's with us in
London comes up with a camera and he
starts filming me and the second the
camera comes over my Panic goes away
immediately and I'm like
I'm doing okay and he's like he's like
you're good and I was like I'm good and
he's like and I'm looking around I go
where's the mat you know and he's like
down and I'm acting like I'm and I get
pulled out I get down to the bottom
and we [__] around and we swim around
the boat but anytime I feel Panic around
my brain I just go find the camera and
I'm like oh hey take my take my
regulator out I'm like smile and my
brain's like very like clear the air
and then of course run out of air at 90
[__] feet like from 90 feet I'm
breathing like crazy oh yeah instructor
comes over looks at my thing is like you
need to go up now and I was like huh and
she was like and I'm in the red I'm like
oh I've been breathing like crazy and
I'm drop we were supposed to say it like
70 feet I dropped down to 90 feet the
whole time which Cuts all your time in
half yeah and so we have to go up and
now I'm running out of air going up and
I'm like I just gotta find the camera if
I find the camera I'm not gonna die wow
and so I'm just like looking for the
camera looking for the camera my buddy
John man swims up and I'm like okay
running out of air and everyone's like
what I'm like we're gonna be fine like
and I buddy breathe with my instructor
we get to the top we got to sit at like
15 feet for like five minutes or
whatever so they bring a [__] squid
down with all the [__] things on and
I'm breathing off that I'm like okay so
we get up I go I did it I did it I did
it and I persevered I persevered I'm
like all right I'm gonna get in the boat
and my instructor goes you have one more
dive hey what she goes you have one more
dive
I need to take you to 30 feet for five
minutes and then you can get your
instruction your your certification
and I'm like so me and you were just
gonna go sit at 30 feet like No cameras
no nothing
[__] time
oh but yeah but like the second and
that's nothing to make you panic more
than being underwater like that for sure
sometimes it's someone explaining it to
you and they go next time you're next to
a nine-story building look up and that's
how much water is on top of you and I
was I remember just being like
and I remember getting we were in Denver
we were I was next to a 10-story
building and I was like
all that water's gonna be on top of me
and it just [__] me up yeah I've seen
some of the baddest [__] Panic
underwater I've panicked underwater like
really oh yeah yeah especially if the
tides rip and everything in your feel
like you're losing control like that I
think for anxiety sufferers not being in
control in nature yeah the worst feeling
and like lightning underwater that's the
type of [__] that will trigger it I hope
we went swimming with whale sharks in
Japan and I got down there and they're
going to be down there for 40 minutes
and I was like cool and then five
minutes in all I could think was I have
35 more minutes of this 35 more minutes
and I was like and me and the Sharks
looking at me like
I'm not going anywhere and I just
remember going like I need a camera I
need someone to talk to like I get this
is [__] killing me yeah I might
I used to take I used to take uh Xanax
whenever I got panic attacks I don't
have to take Xanax
and I found the less I drink the more
manageable my anxiety is I know that and
like there's certain foods like I cannot
eat spicy foods because it just my
stomach dictates my anxiety I find
certain alcohols are worse like wine
[__] me up really red wine is a donut
like I feel my most depressed that day
after being on red wine whereas whiskey
I can [__] go all night and be pretty
cool really yeah I uh apparently it's
full of um preservatives yeah so far
okay so so that's why there's a I don't
know if they're sponsors are you but fit
Vine have you ever heard of fitvine
they're [__] awesome oh really
because they have no sugars no sulfites
no tannins all the [__] that all the
toxic [__] that gets in your body yeah
that gives you the hangover that that
they have none of it and that's the same
as Serbian wine so I'm drinking bottle
of Serbian wine every night because it's
like cheap one you know I mean cheap but
like no one in Serbia has 40 spent on a
bottle of wine so they make Home Wines
that are a little less complex but a
little healthier and that's why I could
run every morning yeah I I uh I love how
we're sort of an alcoholics let me tell
you something tips listen to this human
so yeah I uh I I've fine-tuned it even
though I can say that and man it's so
funny
if I so when we fly everyone meets at my
house I I only fly now to I mean to do
the road really so everyone will meet my
house
um Peter
man's my cameraman uh and then the other
comics and then my trainer Lacy well
meet at my house
man like [__] clockwork this I mean
it's insane the SEC I'll be fine all day
the second everyone starts showing up
I started having my my I get blinders on
my stomach hurts I feel physically ill
my head feels tight and I'm like my butt
starts sweating I'm like I got I'm like
I gotta take a [__] or something like
and then Leanne's like honey it's this
is normal this is what you're going this
is normal and I'm like this is crazy
like it doesn't make sense why this
happens I I don't happen when we get in
the bus we're in the bus the other night
driving in the middle of the night
hitting so much bumps from [__]
Birmingham or whatever just if that was
a plan I'd be losing my [__] [__]
losing my [__] I have had such anxiety
on planes I want time I one time grabbed
a black woman's hand and started holding
her hand and I was like I'm so sorry
that I have to do this and she was like
it's okay it's okay you're gonna be fine
I'm like I'm [__] I wear sunglasses
when I fly because I will cry I will
start crying oh yeah it's
and then I just I could I give up every
time every time I go through the same
thing I if especially if I'm sober like
turns over October I give up and I go
what the [__] why can't I get what is
wrong I look at people reading a book I
go so you're just gonna read a book into
the grave like you're gonna die reading
a [__] book like a world I I think
you visualize the plane going down you
imagine it I wait for it I wait to just
hear a and then and then I'm like oh
that's and that's what you'll feel are
like a you know like I wait for it I I
think about it if I have
one two drinks doesn't happen just
and then I'm like I'm fine I'm gonna
take a nap I'll take a something called
Sertraline which is like a
antidepressant but it helps you with
your anxiety as well just takes the edge
right off well here's the problem guys I
think my anxiety helps me create so like
my favorite feeling in the in the world
is hung over a [__] with a cup of coffee
in me a little bit you know like a
little shooting everywhere and creative
people always like that I love the
[__] I love my wife calls it fire and
hot and uh and I've had some some of the
hardest laughs early in the morning hung
over with a cup of coffee I've been so
creative I feel it's like when I write
in my journal or I go out and do my
gratitudes and get Morning Sun and I
just feel like I love that energy you
know it's
both have anxiety uh Georgia God damn it
man that kid's Liam was really smart she
watched me go through anxiety and then
second George I got her first panic
attack
I was almost like a part of me was like
it's like almost like going like seeing
your kid wearing if you're a Yankees
fancy and your kid walk out in the
Yankees jersey and you're like ah you're
me you're one of the and I was like but
then the other party was like [__] it's
not it's not the Yankees it's like being
a Brewers fan you're like oh great dude
you're gonna be rooting for the losing
team for the rest of your life and I
remember saying I remember
Leanne was like it's nothing and I
identified it was an anxiety attack I
said oh baby you're having a panic
attack
and I said I was having a drink at the
time sat with her on my lap on my
recliner and I said hey this is what I
have this is what I go through all the
time you're not dying you're not dying
you just need to breathe I said you want
to sit on the toilet and try to take a
[__] she was like uh-huh I was a good
sit on the toilet and then she went on
the toilet I remember we hear just
and then I go come on out and I go
listen it's totally cool you're gonna
live through this you're going to live
through this you're not dying today
today is not the day you die and we
talked it through and then Leanne like a
gangster immediately gets her a [__]
therapist immediately George must have
been 10 12. get your therapist to work
through anxiety and then Georgia has all
these tools to work through anxiety Isle
gets anxiety Georgia identifies it tells
my wife yo Isla's got anxiety you need
to get her with doctors whatever her
name is Dr Smiles or whatever and so
they go and do it with Isla and now both
my daughters in moments of panic have
all these tools to operate with that I
do not [__] have I remember
I have a hard time I have sleep anxiety
and so like a lot of times I'll lay in
bed and I'll just and I'm not going to
bed then it gets worse like especially
if I have something big to do like do a
special or something yeah oh it's like
um oh it makes me crazy thinking about
it and uh
I remember George was like
George gave me her tools one night and
when I was in Cleveland they were I was
doing my special and I couldn't sleep
and I wasn't drinking
and George and ILO in the other room and
I got up and George was like are you
still awake and I said yeah and she goes
I said I'm trying to count sheep and she
goes that that doesn't work don't make
your mind active dad and I was like what
she goes you're not gonna go to sleep if
you're thinking about things you need to
have nothing in your brain you need to
think of nothing
actively think of nothing dad and I was
like the [__] are you talking about she
was like that's what doctor Smiles or
whatever said to us Dr Smiley said to us
to actively think of dad try to clear
your brain try your hard and not think
of anything so I went to bed and I'm
like I'm nothing I'm doing nothing
nothing nothing and then you're laying
there all sudden your brain goes horses
wearing cowboy boots you're like what
the [__] and you're like oh [__] I think
I'm falling asleep
and then I'm like oh my God and then now
I don't do it all the time but now like
now if I can if I'm like because
sometimes you get caught in the thought
and it'll be repeating a thought over
and over and over again but so yeah
Leanne identified it with the girls and
now the girls are [__] gangsters you
can still see like you know they're
still growing and stuff but yeah does
that moment make you feel like a good
dad when you first identified it did you
feel useful I've there's only a few
times I felt useful teaching them to
ride bikes teaching them to swim and
when they got anxiety attacks no because
I wasn't really visualizing that I
thought I bet you felt like a good guy I
felt like a great dad there's a I mean I
have a list of times Georgia would know
that I was like that I didn't I mean the
best dad thing I ever did was this is
the best dad thing I ever did Georgia in
La you turned 16 you can get a car but
you can't have people in your car until
you're 17. so Leanne pulls up at a
[__] light and George is next to her
in her car with [__] nine girls and
they're dancing in the car Leanne sees
it waits calls Georgia they're out of
light calls Georgia Georgia's like
everyone shut up she's like hello and
George Leanne goes look to your left and
during the looks and goes and Leanne's
like I'll see you at home in five
minutes
so she calls me and I go
all right
and I realized in this moment what I've
been doing is what my dad did my dad
would take his energy up to here it
would shut me down and then I would I
would try to course correct based on his
energy so I was doing that with Georgia
I'd get mad I take it up to here I'd
raise my voice I'd [__] be God damn
it what the [__] you know yeah and in
that moment I realized
I'm setting her up so that all she knows
is I go to a level 10. so why wouldn't
she lie to us why wouldn't she like she
goes if I lie well
he's he's I have a chance of getting
away with it but exactly if I get caught
he's going here anyway yeah and so I had
to teach her that I there were I had
different levels of how I dealt with her
and so she came home and I was like
she goes I guess I'm grounded I said no
you're not grounded and Leanne's still
out she goes what I said you're not
grounded I was like I don't think you
you weren't doing drugs or anything you
said girls in the car he said yeah you
can't have girls in the car he's like
well see them with my punishment like
being real [__] I said
I want you to write
a thousand words like a thousand words
down because she's a writer so she
thinks really well when she writes
on how it feels when I get angry with
you
like how do you feel
and then what's the best way for me to
operate within there
she's like are you being serious and I
was like yeah and she started bawling
crying she was like what's what happened
to you and I was like nothing I realized
I'm [__] up by getting angry I go I'm
not mad at you I just think that if I'm
angry that's the way I teach you but I
don't think I'm teaching you that way
and she's like you're not you're not
teaching me that way and I was like I
don't want you to lie to me I want you
to be truthful so go out with your
friends you can't drive any of them you
still go out go out have a good time
tonight you cannot drive them do you
understand that she's like I understand
I understand when do you want these ten
thousand or the thousand words by and I
was like Wow Leanne came home and it's
like where the [__] is she I go she went
out with her friends and Leah's like
what the [__] I go I go I think I
handled it and then I told Leanne on
Leanne's like what happened to you and
it's just this Moment of clarity where I
realized
I was coming here every time it's like
if it's like why it's like if you have a
[__] wife
who's a [__] and a piece of [__] she's
always yelling at you why wouldn't you
cheat on her like why wouldn't you just
cheat on her like what the [__] like
you're already a [__] I don't well I
got [__] all the time yeah might as
well just go out and have fun and
whatever come home I get [__] yeah so I
think a lot of people missed that point
in life yeah oh yeah yeah people uh
people want everything their own way and
they forget that there's a you it's all
that that old saying you know you get
more in uh is it with honey than [__]
yeah basically and you you you played a
real smart role I did I've done that a
couple times with George Mila and I are
buddies like I mean
uh Leanne and Isla butt heads George and
I butt heads what about your dad because
actually one interesting thing I learned
on the Louis CK podcast is he worked for
Scientology as a lawyer yeah wow like L
Ron Hubbard yeah [__] yeah he was uh so
he's right it was probably when I was
like eight or nine my dad represented a
a man or a woman I believe it was a
woman who
I might have been a dude who was a drug
addict and uh had they had put him in he
was part of the family members were in
the church they put him into the church
and he was abused or something or
something bad happened and my dad
represented him and he got out of the
church and he sued the church and my dad
won him a bunch of money and then the
church came to my dad and was like
anyone who can beat us is good enough
for us we want you on our team so they
put him on a retainer him and my my dad
and his partner and gave him a big chunk
of money to be like you're now the
church lawyers and so we bought a house
with it uh my dad we moved out of like
more of a more of a
I don't want to say white trash
neighborhood but a white trash
neighborhood moved to a like a nice
community that house
and uh yeah I remember I I thought
nothing was wrong with church
Scientology because John Travolta was in
it Christy alley was in it misman cheers
was going on yeah and so like I knew all
the people in the church I didn't know
of Tom Cruise really at the time but
like and so I was like yeah there's
nothing wrong with church Scientology I
remember my dad if any church thing
happened my dad would be like no one
talked to a [__] soul
and then the church stiffed him and they
uh was it was he worried about what they
because he obviously knew some of their
problems he knew all of it all right
yeah he was like because they'll lock
you down and like
I remember I remember being familiar
with the word Dianetics like I'm and so
like my dad was like and my dad's just a
very skeptical person he's a my dad's
like a really great dude he's really
smart yeah and uh and he just didn't
trust them he didn't you know but like
there was always weird there was a biker
group that would come over and the
Outlaws and so like my dad would be in a
lawyer you just had weird [__] people
around at times but yeah they were and
so they test you right yeah and
um you did you have Leah Remini talk
about this yeah Leah Remini Leah Remini
was on uh the cabin she did an episode
of the cabin but we had to get rid of
the episode because you know so that's a
long story
[Laughter]
that is such a funny way of I think that
was a long story uh it was a long story
but yeah Leah Remini was on and I was
like yeah my dad was the lawyer for the
church and then I didn't realize you
know I was really hot button top top oh
yeah yeah she had a hell of a time
machine on [__] hell of a time yeah
yeah because she was the one who spoke
out early
um and yeah my wife went to an acting
school that the church runs the Church
of science I shouldn't say the church
like I'm one of them but like the Church
of Scientology runs right so my wife
used to have this best friend who was a
[__] lunatic like a like a real
broken woman and uh and so my my wife
and her go to acting school and the
church Scientology runs it Church
Scientology has a few like look it's
like the [__] liver King they're
gonna Something's Gonna Make [__]
sense even if even if they're [__] up
and they're crazy and they're not lying
to you and they're not telling you the
truth the liver King had some good
[__] points yeah he did right now
clearly clearly he was just going about
it the wrong way but like he had good
points yeah still to this day he has
good points and so you really bought in
huh what he was a nice guy and like I
love the idea of like there should be
some kind of like ceremonial
bloodletting for boys at a certain
period where they have to like earn
their [__] Stripes I think I think
moving's great I think I'm not gonna
sleep on a [__] mat on the floor
getting outside cold Expo I like all the
things he said it's just like obviously
whatever he he went about it the wrong
way the church is the same way church is
the liver King they're the liver King
they really are yeah look they're
they're not gonna found not that many
people are going to land on horse [__]
and one of the things they had was like
this like
like one of the things they had in the
church that that I still think is a good
idea is that you need to reward yourself
when you do big things you need to get
yourself something nice and reward
yourself so you can commemorate that
nice thing and I was like yes because
like if I do a special I was like I did
a big tour and I was like I want to get
a watch to remember this tour so I
bought a Submariner ten thousand dollars
a nice [__] watch and I was like yeah
and every time I look at that watch I
think about that door and I go how much
I love that watch
um one of the things they did was like
this brutal honesty about like calling
people out and and holding people
accountable the church did it and I
remember she came back from acting class
and her friends were there and her
friends like this
this came ridiculous they set him a
[__] and that I sleep with men to get
power and then I try to use that power
to threaten the met and I'm like she
does all of this and she's like it's
because this church Scientology is
[__] up and I was like I think they're
hitting it on the head how long do they
spend with you 10 minutes yeah but uh we
had to uh I've never I've never I'm not
like I'm I'm not like a religious guy
I'm a religious guy but more like
Catholic [__] where it's just like
rituals so yeah I've seen you talk to
Louis about that about one wishing that
you had that level of Faith because you
seem to be kind of I don't know if we're
all not wanting to die but you
particularly seem to be a bit more on
edge about your own end yeah because I'm
hyper aware of
I can find I have these periods of time
I don't know what it is but like I don't
know if it's I don't know if it's
depression but I don't know what it is
but I'm hyper aware of sadness like I
can see sadness in people
and I can and I'm I'm
do you know the noise like when
like a
I don't know this it's horrible to say
but like the noise when real tragedy
happens and and all of a sudden
everyone's civility goes out the door
and a real scream comes out and people
start saying Panic things for some
reason
I am always very close to that I'm very
tuned into that and I and I I will wake
up I did it this morning and I will and
I think
at one point it goes dark and then I no
longer exist just like I didn't exist
when Charlemagne was around
and it
guts me it guts me yeah like and I I
mean it gives me like a like that kind
of feel where you're like God damn it
let's get this
I'm stealing out of here what the [__]
is that and so it would be nice it would
be very nice if I could find the thing
like Scientology I mean I'm being dead
serious if I could believe it if I could
believe it believe it and go yeah a
spaceship will take me away one day
but if I could believe that I would
[__] pay I'll do whatever the [__]
they want I'll give them the money I'll
[__] hangout with yes
it takes us all away I met this girl I
had this girl Brogan had her on the
podcast she's beautiful beautiful she
was like a CNN journalist and she became
like a psychedelic adventurer
she had this Ayahuasca trip and it and
it changed her
and she had anxiety and then she no
longer had anxiety no longer had anxiety
she came to my house
she goes yeah
this is just a skin suit I'm wearing as
soon as I'm done with this skin too I'm
gonna get a new one and I'll probably go
to space and I went and I was like I
mean I was like she's out of her [__]
mind yeah but I was like I would love to
be out of my mind I would love I would
love the confidence she just said that
with one day I get a new spacesuit have
you done it no no no I have a hard time
eating mushrooms yeah I have a hard time
smoking too much weed like I'm just I'm
I I don't have I don't have control over
it I can't imagine being like I guess
I'll let the snake eat me and then just
on Ayahuasca [__] that I'm so many
there's so many [__] risks it's like
what if I'm allergic to like something
in the thing and then I'm really dying
like I don't know I can't do you also
need to hold on to who you are do you
feel really attached to that because you
I remember you saying on the with Louis
I feel special and I like that yeah I
like that you said that I do that's why
I don't want to die like that's why I
don't want to die I feel like I'm
special I don't I don't understand the
people that don't like Rogan doesn't
think he's special right he does not he
does not and then he'll say just so you
know you're not special either and then
I will look at him and go just you know
we're both special and you're more
special than me
I remember him telling me I wasn't
famous one time and I was like he goes
[__] you're not [__] famous and I go
I'm I'm kind of famous and he goes
you're not famous because he goes I know
you're not famous because I know I'm not
famous and I was like [__]
you're very famous I go you're famous
enough that my dad knows who the [__]
you are I was like what world do you
live in that you know I go [__] Ari
is famous so like what the [__] so yeah
I I definitely feel special I've always
felt special do you think you have
narcissistic Tendencies sure I'm sure I
miss maliane says it I'm a soft
narcissist yeah like I don't have I
don't I would never hurt anyone but I do
have like [__] I remember one time when
I was a kid we were at church and my dad
and and I just dropped to my knees and
started praying my dad's like what the
[__] and I was like nothing he goes what
are you doing I go I'm thanking God he
goes for what I said oh my God given
abilities and he goes like what I said
athleticism my dad goes you're not that
great of an athlete buddy I go okay
and I was a kid like I believed I
believed my dad had the hardest time
raising me because I was
did I believe you were destined oh yeah
I was like sports definitely my thing
like I'll be the greatest baseball
player that ever played 35 Rogan said
you'd be a hell of an athlete if you
weren't such a drunk yeah I heard that
that's my favorite my favorite is to to
uh under promise over deliver I think I
do that with everything under promise
over deliver every man out there that's
a line to live your life by yeah
especially with women yeah yeah and then
the best is let them think nothing of
you and show up like a [__] gangster
I remember when we played tennis me and
Tom Tom had his trainer with him his
wife his kids cameramen he's had
everything and I showed up hungover I've
been partying with Steve Austin the
night before
yeah I've been partying all night I'm
sorry I stopped but what is Stone Cold
Steve Austin like [__] awesome oh
awesome I love this guy he is he does
not let down yes he does yeah like he's
just there and he's like you son of a
[__] yeah he's the [__] best dude
wasn't drinking at the time he wasn't
drinking and I said that sucks and he
goes why I said I just wanted to drink
it he goes then we drink and we just
started drinking beers and we got
[__] wasted we ate steaks and I was
like this is [__] great he is the
best he is the best so I go I show up
and I Ace Tom like 29 times
and the look on Tom's face when he got
the the defeat I saw in that man the
defeat
was almost similar to when I had to roll
him into the hospital when he broke his
arm and knee like that defeat that
defeated look I love that I do that I I
love
when people expect nothing of you and
then you show up and you [__] ball
and they're like what the [__] I did it
with uh we were at the fully loaded
Festival we do it at ballparks one night
I'm hammered we're all sitting there and
the team shows up we're on we're taking
down the stage and the team the baseball
team shows up and they've been to the
show and they're one guy's like I heard
you used to play baseball I said I did
he goes well let's see if you can hit
one out of the park and I was like okay
and it tells like I bet he doesn't hit
one out of the infield and I was like
Dave Attell I'm about to take your money
and I get up there and I was hitting and
by the way now I was hitting one hops
off the fence but the guy the pitcher
looks at me and he goes
there's no Pace on this ball like he's
just like this okay he goes if I put a
little bit of pace on this ball you're
hitting it out of here and then I was
like I'm about to hurt myself I mean I
love it's a benching one of my favorite
things ever we bring how great was this
one of the guys on our tour Dave
Williamson is an athlete and he's a
strong dude big guy right
we should do a max bench press and
everyone's like yeah yeah and Dave's
like wow I got this he gets pinned at
225 and he's like what the [__] me and
Pete are at 235 2 45 wow 255 and then
all of a sudden he was the defeat in his
face like how the [__] are you a
competitor then yeah yeah but then I
have to swallow that because I don't I
can get competitive and it does it's not
a healthy thing for me like uh the
marathon like Joe we were all sitting
around we're [__] around
and I said I'm pretty sure I could run a
marathon with no training and Joe's like
absolutely not and I go I definitely can
and he goes absolutely not I go I
actually I will I will and I ran the LA
marathon with no training I partied the
night before showed up at five in the
morning registered you know a month
before showed him five in the morning
and ran the LA Marathon of five hours 33
minutes and 33 seconds
I ran it for the [__] moment
where Joe looked at me and goes you ran
the LA [__] marathon with no training
the moment that I guess one time Joe and
Cam and Ari were all together yeah yeah
and Ari's like such a shitster and he's
in the back of the car and he's like hey
Cameron did you see what Bert did and
Cam's like he ran the LA marathon with
no [__] training and Joe's just
shaking his head those moments I think
those are better than the guy that busts
his ass in the gym oh yeah yeah turning
up and like showing people a lot they
never thought you could do that yeah
such a good feeling but yeah you know
when you talk about Destiny I'm thinking
you had your whole life feeling that you
were special but then when you don't end
up feeling special like in your late 20s
feel a bit of a it's almost harder to go
through that so when it all turned out
well for you in the end was that was
that feeling like so wait I knew I was
special no no so there was a moment
where I had to realize I wasn't
I got off it
stays at the store I wasn't a Pat I
wasn't passed as a paid regular I was
43.
um everything was kind of falling apart
in my life at the time I was I fired
from Travel Channel I I mean we were
supposed to do this big tour Tom and I
were supposed to this tour with Joey
Diaz and everyone was on it fluffy
Sebastian Dane everyone was on it and
then they kicked me not just pulled me
off
and I remember telling Tom
I was like yeah it sucks I'm not doing
any of the dates now and Tom's like
that's a lot of money and I was like I
was only two thousand dollars a weekend
and Tom was like what I was like yeah
it's only two thousand dollars a week
and he goes that's what you're getting
paid and I go what are you getting paid
and he goes I don't want to tell you I
was like wait what are you getting paid
he goes I'm getting paid 20 grand a show
and I went
and all of that
plus Leanne's redoing the house I'm
fired from Travel Channel
I put out my special on Showtime no one
watches it I'm not a paid regular at the
store I'm coming off the store I'm
overweight Tom's fat shaming me I have
no shirt on I have a pair of dad jeans
on I don't have cool shoes on and I
remember I saw a dude I saw a dude
uh who was
gorgeous comedian gorgeous he had the
car he had the car that I had seen
because we were looking to buy a new car
it was the one that they had in the
showroom he had that car the one the
showroom the Audi he had that car and he
had a girl with him who's one of the
most beautiful women I've ever seen in
my entire life and he was ignoring her
standing outside his car texting and
clothes that looked like he was about to
go to outer space like it was it was
like fashion clothes
and I realized though this is this is
who I am like I'm not I'll never I'll
never be that guy I'll never be with
that girl I'm this guy who's overweight
and um and it's and it could not happen
it may not happen for me and I remember
I remember having that moment a few
times and I was like uh
I don't I don't think that's my story I
remember just being like I think I can I
think I can bust my ass I think I can
outwork everyone I think I can come up
with I'm just gonna [__] double down
on me and I started I started leaning
into the fat shaming stuff and then
posting videos and doing workout videos
and editing and focusing on my Instagram
and like really focusing on my podcast
and it was all the same time that Joe
and Tom and everyone was like you know
you should get away from your travel
channel stuff and all that stuff kind of
culminated
and then and then the the real moment I
had the real Moment of clarity I had was
when Tom and I were doing our fast
shaming the person who didn't lose the
most amount of weight had to lose the
beard and I remember talking to Leanne
and being like I'm worried I'm gonna
lose my beard and she goes so what
I said what do you mean he goes it grows
back and I was like yeah she goes Bert
who do you think people are going to
Google more
when you go to this weight loss
challenge
the guy that lost the beard or the guy
that won the challenge and I was like oh
everyone's going to want to see what I
look like with my fat face she goes if
you're talking content that's really
good content and I was like really she
goes don't stress about this weight loss
thing lose weight have fun it should be
fun you're not a [__] bodybuilder
you're a comedian and if you lose you're
going to look ridiculous and everyone's
going to Google you and you'll probably
sell tickets and I went
and I remember I sold at the first show
I did January 10th I sold every people
were coming to my shows to see what I
looked like without a beer like they
were like ah and then and then I'm a
real comic so I'm doing great comedy and
they're like God this guy's [__]
hilarious and and then at that moment
that that six years ago I turned I chose
to move my life in the in the direction
I wanted to be in no boss no no one I
did everything my own everything was
like I'll do it all my edit it I'll post
it I'll do everything on my own I'm good
and I took control of my career the same
way Rogan did when Rogan got kicked out
of the [__] store and he wasn't
allowed to come back there and he was
like [__] it I'm starting a podcast I'm
gonna do Spots I'm gonna do the road
more I'm gonna do my podcast I'm gonna
focus on my standup I'll do the ice
house when you those moments of like
struggle I think are such a great
opportunity to reassess and rebuild and
and and and there's nothing more
motivating than wanting to someone to go
God I was wrong about him doctor's the
[__] I have a list of short names
short list of names of people that I
just I wonder if they're going like
[__] man we really dropped a ball on
that guy that guy actually was more than
I thought he was so I think you know all
of that
it's funny I look back at that time in
my life
and and I look very fondly on it on
towards the thinking of it I would never
want to do it again I would never want
to do there again I mean it's terrifying
I remember it's Christmas time and I was
like I was like [__] like what it is our
last good Christmas where everyone gets
good presents like I remember like
there's really creepy thought that's the
thing I talk about when I think of like
I'm I'm tapped into sadness sometimes
like where I think real things like what
if this is our last good Christmas
oh [__] I mean I haven't been able to
buy a house without thinking I'm dying
like I go huh I wish I'd get to live in
this house but I'll be dead by the time
we get in here I think of that all the
time yeah so those Rock Bottom moments
they feel [__] horrendous at the time
but then you look back at them you're
like wow that was the real window
opening door opening moment that I
didn't realize it forced you to become a
better version of who you are there's
nothing better than
like I remember going
I remember being like I'll just post
this video
and then and then and I was like if no
one watches it they're already not
watching it
I remember it was a video of me going
like I was getting a cup of coffee I go
a lot of people ask me I was the
stupidest [__] video like a lot of
people ask me how I get on the gym how
like how I party but I can get on the
treadmill the next day it's super easy
like it just starts with music and I hit
uh
Midnight Special by Creedence Clearwater
Let The Midnight Special
shine a light on me and I just go you
gotta feel the music feel the music
Tommy and I'm just taunting Tom and I
get on the treadmill I go dance your
first couple steps Let The Midnight
Special and then I start running and I
go I'm coming after you Tommy like I was
like I didn't think anyone's gonna see
it I posted it I do my workout I get off
the treadmill and the first person that
called me was Rogan and he was like what
is that [__] song like oh the uh the
one I just posted like a Midnight
Special he goes dude I [__] Lyman
listen to Credence in Forever that's
[__] awesome and then I looked and it
had like 10 000 views in in like in like
30 minutes which was big for me back
then I was like whoa and then all of a
sudden it had a hundred thousand views
and then someone was like hey we want to
add shows and I was like what and then I
just was like oh you can get paralyzed
by over analyzing things just [__] do
it post it who gives a [__] you know my
first podcast I ever did talk mom just
walked in hit record gave it Mike to
Joey my dad him and me and he goes this
is your first podcast do not edit it do
not do anything record it upload it post
it and I went for real and he goes do
not he's like you're overthinking this
and I hit record posted it
now I've been doing podcasts for [__]
10 goddamn years but like that over
analyzing [__] I think it cripples
people like me for real especially
Comics I watched a dude love this dude
love this dude got a new special on NBC
Sean Patton [__] hilarious dude right
when stories came out
we're in Salt Lake City and I've been
blowing up on stories I've been using
the Instagram stories a lot I'm selling
tickets to it I showed Sean and Sean's
like yeah yeah and I watch him try to
make a story about making a cup of tea
right and so he gets his phone and he
like makes the tea and then he hits it
and he's like
okay nope and then and I'm sitting on
the couch and I'm recording him do his
stories I'm recording him I'm putting
like I put like 15 up of his outtakes of
the tea he never posted the video of him
taking the tea never posted it and I had
a hundred and fifty thousand views
people were losing it on him trying to
make them and he never posted the video
and I was like that is that's the thing
there you go you can get caught up in so
much of the [__] that you just don't
post anything but [__] it let it suck
let it suck you gotta fail you hung up
with Conor McGregor recently yeah in
Dublin at his Pub what was that like uh
caught me off guard I didn't expect I
did not expect it
we I mean I we just I mean I was
taunting in the whole week I was like
saying well if I see him I don't care
I'll slap you know whatever just being
talking [__] because he didn't think
he'd ever run into him yeah and so then
someone's like you're gonna go to the
black Forge in
I go we'll go there I'm [__] yeah we'll
go there take some pictures I'll tag
Conor McGregor for me it's about like
just tag him and people like yeah but
it's fun it's fun
so we show up and the second we show up
everyone's kind of hustling around and I
was like Wow and there's a Bentley in
the front and I'm like oh [__] someone's
Bentley's here and I'm like I bet they
park it out here every night so people
think he's in here that's what I thought
so we walk in the manager grabs me and
he's like
come on we got your table ready
and he's like and I was like oh thank
you so much he goes you're gonna you
wanna meet the boss man tonight and I
was like well yeah yeah I don't want to
say thank you to whoever and he's like
because we can make it happen but it's
got to happen quick we get everyone get
your cameras out and I was like wait who
are you talking about he goes Connor and
I said what he goes he's right there
he's at the table next to us I'm like
I start Mel I'm like [__] Conor
McGregor Conor McGregor's right there
holy [__] he's like yeah he wants to
meet you you know come on I don't think
Connor knew who I was in all fairness I
don't think he knew who I was I think he
I don't think I take that back because
he did tell me to say tell Joe I said hi
all right and so he might have known who
I was I think they were aware that I had
a lot of big Instagram following and I
think that was the thing I think I don't
know yeah so
Connor comes over and he's like hey
[__] awesome delivers delivers I mean
what's up ah come on let's get a picture
huh get the belt get the belt on the guy
and then get the belt on me and we do
the fist thing and then he's like what
are you doing in Ireland and I'm like I
did the O3 Arena and he goes
really I said yeah you sell it out and I
said yeah and he comes in close he goes
man you sold out the O3 Arena
immediately makes it about him
I'll just try and have a conversation be
[__] hilarious he goes me and you how
solid thing I go we did and then he was
like I'm taking my shirt off and he goes
okay and I ripped my shirt off I take
another picture and he's like ah and
then he was coolest [__] guy
guy and then I get up I go to the
bathroom I start taking pictures with
fans and Connor sees like you know
everyone's got their cameras out and
he's not gonna let him down he comes
down we take pictures of a couple people
I do a video with them and then we and I
was like I just I pulled him aside I was
like dang dude thank you this is such a
big I go I I you have no idea how much
joy you gave me to watch you fight it
was so much fun yeah it was like or my
treat when you'd fight because I had
someone to root for and I [__] I have
all your old school shirts and he was
just very generous and then you know his
hope his mom came up she was like can I
get a picture with you and I was like
[__] yeah I think his name's Maggie
McGregor yeah yeah and so uh took a
picture with his mom and we just had a
[__] blast and and then had a great
[__] steak that had a great goddamn
steak at that place it looks nice to be
fair like it was great it was amazing I
was shocked there weren't more people I
don't know if they weren't letting
people in but it was like it was evenly
filled meaning like everyone was at a
table no one was crowding no one was
gawking no one was taking pictures it
was like evenly filled did you try the
um like the kids yeah no no I tried his
his Stout yeah I had a stout I loved it
I loved it but I I'm an easy sell like
if you you know like if you're sitting
next to me I'm an easy [__] self yeah
he's going through a lot right now he's
got this uh woman who just jumped off of
his [__] yacht last year and claimed
that he
tucked her she's [__] jumped off his
yacht got
um
picked up by the Red Cross and then uh
he's all just been knocked over on his
bike I don't know if you've seen that as
well on his Instagram he was riding his
bike some guy blinded by the sunlight
drove straight through him nearly
[__] killed him he is [__] jacked
yeah he looks for sure like trust me
when I say
he is wide as [__] he is wide he is hard
as a rock and I looked at I don't know
what did they say his height is I think
they said 510 I was looking at eye to
eye I thought with that [__] and
I'm six one I was like I was like holy
[__] he is jacked I mean jacked and he
smells amazing and his clothes are so
soft it's they're so nice like when you
touch him your hands just go oh Royal
it's funny because he's actually gone at
Joe Rogan a bit and yeah yeah they were
going back and forth about steroids well
and Joe like Joe says what he sees and
obviously Conor's got an eagle so when
Joe is literally commentating on him
getting his ass kicked he has to say
what's happening yeah and Conor doesn't
like that so he's like digging him out
on uh Twitter for like oh I was fighting
I was fighting you're [__] this on
the other uh but Joe was actually the
first person to even really tweet about
Conor in the UFC yeah he he said like
this guy is he's the guy he was uh he he
said to me I texted Joe I said yo I'm
sitting next Conor McGregor and Joe's
like of course you are
and and he's like tell him I said hi and
then Connor came by and he's like tell
Joe I said hi I said Joe just texted and
said to say hi and he goes tell him I'll
see him soon see him real soon in the
ring and I was like oh I guess he's
coming back to fight yeah and so uh of
course I texted Joe and then I texted
them pictures and they're like and then
Joe's like of course you took your
[__] shirt off
yeah Conor McGregor was awesome man I
think we have it to wrap it up now so
I'll ask you my last question shoot
which is
we've talked a lot about you this so
it's a good one I'm done how would you
like to be remembered
in the event that you're not here
anymore which hopefully the aliens come
and take you away I want I I I'm gonna
cry this time that [__] me up that
question [__] me up really yeah because
I know that'll happen one day and you
and I want to be remembered I want to be
remembered I think you made sure that
that will happen bro I'm trying my
hardest it's all my life is is that I
want I just want uh
why am I [__] crying it's all good
man I just want people like like when
they're having a good time to go oh man
I wish Bert was here
that's the silliest thing just like when
you know he would have made this so much
more fun like that's it like I don't
need to be like I don't need to cure
anything or like fix anything
you're a good time I just want people to
be like God man oh Meek right if bird
was here you're the best time it's the
silliest thing do you want to be
remembered
the [__] you don't want to [__] fix
it
I don't know I just want people to go
Bert would have gotten the shots
[__] that I love that that is one of my
favorite answers I've ever had in that
question but and you are 100 that guy
well 100
a hundred percent ladies and gentlemen
bird crochet on the true Jolly podcast
what a legend we love you thank you
thanks very much great that was great
love it cheers brother